From the Library of Congress in Washington, DC
Anyway where I’m going to try and [inaudible]as
best I can since you’re not going to be
able to have them in front of you.
We’re going to begin sort of slowly kind of talking
a bit about the providence of this new acquisition.
It was originally called the Codex Quetzalecatzin.
We’re changing that name to the Mapa.
Some Codex is a little bit of a misnomer as
far as this codex, or mapa, is concerned.
It’s a single sheet as opposed to a book
and we’re gonna go with the word Mapa Quetzalecatzin
as opposed to codex.
The Library acquired this codex, or mapa,
just a few months ago from a private collector
in France.
And if you haven’t seen it, you can pull
it up on the Library’s website, the actual
image of it while we’re talking here to
actually be able to magnify some of the sections.
So what is in front of you here is the actual
Codex as it exists right now -- there are
a couple parts of it that have been cut off
through its lifetime.
I believe it came from around 1570 and 1593.
And so, it is one of the rare surviving pre-1600
pictorial or manuscripts that have survived
from Mexico and Central America.
The crux? of the manuscript is really interesting.
An artifact is a really something part of
the manuscript’s history.
It was originally owned, we believe, by a
man named Alfredo Chavero.
And he was a Mexican poet, archeologist, sort
of the first people to collect Mexican folktales
and some of the Nahua folk and Nahua poetry.
He donated another codex that he owned, which
is the Chavero Codex Huexotzinco, to the National
Museum of Mexico in 1906.
And we aren’t really sure exactly why this
particular codex did not also go to the National
Museum of Mexico at that time.
Instead, it was purchased by a man named Weetman
Dickinson Peerson.
And he was the First Viscount of Cowdray.
And he was down in Mexico at that time working
on the Tehuantepec Railroad.
When Chavero died in 1906, he actually purchased
Chavero’s entire collection and brought
it back to England with him.
At some point in the intervening years from
1906 to 1939 it was actually purchased by
William Randolph Hearst.
William Randolph Hearst, of course, has other
things here at the Library that he owned before,
which -- something like the Jefferson Bible
– which is often used for inaugurations,
used to be owned by William Randolph Hearst.
By 1939, The Mapa was actually purchased by
Charles Ratton, and he was a collector, gallery
owner in Paris.
He sdfa in African tribal art.
He was one of the first people to actually
see African indigenous art as an art form.
He created some of the early shows at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art on tribal art and
soul tribal art also.
He was friends with many of the Surrealists
during this period and had a group of people
surrank him in Paris at the time.
His partner, Guy Ladriere, became a partner
with Ratton after the war, the World War.
With Ratton’s death in 1986 the Codex was
sent to Guy Ladriere.
And it is from Guy Ladriere that we actually
purchased the Codex itself just a few months
ago.
The Codex is, of course, it’s a Nahua codex.
It’s written in Nahua hieroglyphic text.
It takes its name from the person pictured
here who is Lord-11 Quetzalecatzin who was
a nobleman, landowner in the 1450s/1460s in
the area that is kind of pictured in the Codex.
The Codex is really divided up into two parts
and we’ll talk a little bit about that in
just a little while.
But the Codex is composed of both a map on
one side and the genealogy of the family that
is going to descend from Lord11 Quetzalecatzin.
It is – there’s forms of text on the map
and we’ll --on the manuscript -- and we’ll
talk a little bit more about this.
It is composed Nahua hieroglyphics.
For instance, the Nahua glyph for water that
we see prominently in the figure and to the
right, that is the actual glyph for water
coming out of the mountain home of Lord-11
Quetzalecatzin.
The piece you see in front of you, all on
here you will see that Nahua has been transcribed
into Roman script.
One of the great things about this particular
codex is that the script is very, very readable.
But the genealogical part has not been worked
out at this point and we’ll talk a little
more about that in just a bit.
The Codex, as I said, is divided up into several
parts and the left side of the Mapa is a genealogy.
And it’s a genealogy of a particular family
that is named the Domp DeLeon family.
And the whole family descends down from the
Lord-11 Quetzalecatzin all the way down to
the last member, who died in 1593.
1593 is actually written in Arabic numerals
on the manuscript itself.
The genealogy is composed, of course, of the
images of the various members of the family
who are named in both the Nahua hieroglyphic
text and in the Roman transcription.
And what we ought to see is the numerical
colindrix?
associated with the years of their reign.
One of the interesting things about the Codex
is it talks about the people who are here
not as rulers, as overseers of property, Overseers
of the rural farmers.
We are seeing a group of noble landlords here
who are making this document, at least as
it appears to us now, as a quasi-legal document.
Scholars who study manuscripts like this,
like Elizabeth Boone hill, for example, have
talked about these manuscripts acquiring this,
sort of, quasi-legal status in the late 16th
century.
Basically, it was a time when a lot of the
noble rights and privileges and titles were
being called into question??
So, the manuscript kind of reasserts some
of the powers of the noblemen during a period
when they were very much at risk.
We should concentrate our time this afternoon
on looking on the map side as opposed to the
genealogical side.
The map side is really interesting because
a lot of the place names that we find on the,
map itself and on the manuscript itself.
There’s a lot of really interesting hieroglyphics.
There’s a lot of interesting phonetic compliments,
which I’ll talk about in just a bit, and
also just a lot of ethnobotanical information
that the manuscript kind of puts forward.
Now when we [inaudible] a manuscript like
this, it’s not a single person.
It’s not just me as the curator of the collection
who’s involved.
It requires a real team of people and our
conservators, people like Betsy Haude? and
Silvia Albro who specialize in manuscripts
like this, and some of our science people,
Finla France?, Megan Wilson?, did a lot of
work basically verifying that what we were
looking at was actually the Mapa Quetzalecatzin
from this date.
And so I just wanted to mention that this
was really a team effort and it’s not just
a single person who’s acquiring these for
the Library and it’s important for everyone
to kind of realize that.
We can see that some of the things that show
this is the genealogy of the people in the
family.
You can see the name written there: Domp Deleon,
and the pictures of the various family members
who are in fact named on the manuscript.
Now, outside there are probably, at least
from a graphic standpoint and form a linguistic
standpoint, an extremely interesting manuscript.
This is just a portion of some of the hills
that we see.
These are actually portraying hills and I’ll
show you why that is in just a moment.
We can see here the Nahua glyph for that and
these sort of, schematic representations of
hills and landscape.
And that manuscript is both an ethnobotanical
document it is also an actual map and we’ll
go into a little bit about what that looks
like in just a couple of minutes.
Now if we start looking at some of the place
names, the most common words on the map basically
form themselves like this.
We can see here that we have the Nahua place
name, which is written on the map, and basically
we see this little image of a flower.
And this flower is the Nahua word for the
Plumeria rubra, which is a tiny little flower
but it is a phonetic complement.
Basically, it is allowing the person who’s
reading the map to actually pronounce the
similarities in the two words.
So, a lot of the place names on this utilized
ethnobotanical information in order to construct
these phonetic compliments along through the
toponyms.
For a little bit more explicit this is one,
for instance, we have, basically the translations
is a hill built with red agave.
And the red agave plant, which I show here,
basically the Nahua name kind of sounds like
this.
And this is a typical way that these kind
of things are going to be formed.
So we really see the the hill and then we
see the agave plant representing the word
for the hill filled with red agave.
There are several people who worked on some
of the the glyphic break downs here and some
of the linguistic breakdowns and the toponyms.
I, Myself have been working on them at the
same time as an independent scholar named
Matthew McGath who sent me some of his interpretations,
some of which were better? than the ones that
I were working on.
So I just want to give him credit for actually
working through some of these at the same
time I was.
But it is typical [inaudible] if we can see
a Nahua word broken down like this.
So we see “Tepe” for hill, “tiauh”
for red, “me” for the agave plant, “yoh
“ is the suffix and basically this entire
word is “the hill filled with red agave.”
Other place names are a little more difficult
to figure out what they are.
This one for instance, is actually the Nahua
word for a certain bromeliad species of plant.
I’m not really sure what the actual bromeliad
is at this point, I can only get it down to
the generic name.
And we’ll talk about some of the sources
that have kind of allowed me to get at what
these names actually mean and what the actual
plants that are being talked about on the
map are.
But these are all place names, these are all
toponyms which are reflecting a certain ethnobotanical
or df botanical naming of certain plants which
are very common in the region.
We all know that the codex also has some varying
glyphic work.
For instance here is the glyph for stone and
we also see [inaudible].
This kind of thing that occurs on the map.
Also I just want to point out that these kind
of things, especially the stone and several
other glyphs of this type occur in other ethnobotanical
manuscripts, other manuscripts that have an
ethnobotanical import.
This is the *name* manuscript it is an early
Nahua manuscript which vaguely shows medicinal
plants used throughout the region.
And you’ll see that some of the root systems
in fact, have stone glyphs in them.
So these plants, these particular kinds of
plants, grow in rocky soil.
And so we see the same kind of information
being portrayed on the Codex itself.
The sources for this kind of information,
this sort of decipherment of these, this ethnobotanical
information, one of our best sources is Bernardo
de Sahagun’s History of New Spain.
And Sahagun was a very interesting anthropologist.
He sent out different kinds of surveys to
the Nahua people in the area and got information
back.
And basically, he listed customs and his work
is an enchiconpidaia of sort of Aztec and
Nahua customs.
One of the most interesting parts of that
is really the botanical manuscripts which
he, and the botanical names which he collected.
Some of the sadfaf from the manuscript that
are talking about sdfa are identical with
those found in Sahagun.
Here I’ve got actually some of the stuff
on the agave plant.
We saw the hill filled with red agave on the
manuscript.
Our manuscript, we believe, dates between
1570 and 1593 so it is contemporaneous with
Sahagun’s work.
And some of the plants are pictured kind of
in the same way.
Sahagun writes a great deal on the agave plants
and many of the plants that are on the manuscript
itself.
He talked about the agave as being an extremely
important plant to the Nahua.
He talks about a certain white wine is the
way he says I, but obviously a fermented kind
of beverage was added to various kinds of
medicine.
And the agave plant features quite prominently
on the Mapa Quetzalecatzin.
Another thing for this kind of information
is just go to Hernandez’s Plants and Animals
and Minerals of New Spain: A New History of
Plants and Animals.
Hernandez is an extremely important source,
he is writing in Latin.
Manuscripts, in fact, were not published until
after his death.
They were actually published by the Society
of Linksdfa, which Galileo was a member of,
and they were published in Rome in 1651.
The book is an amazing compendium of botanical
information.
It’s unfortunately never been translated
into English, it is written in Latin and in
Nahua.
There are some extremely interesting events
that Hernandez talks about.
One that I’ll point out is that the Ololiúqui
here, which is one of the great Aztec hallucinogenics
and was one of the most mysterious?
plant for a very long time until it was finally
identified as a morning glory in the 1960s.
And it sort of set of the sort of 1960s hallucinogenic
craze.
It was indemnified by a botanist named Richard
Evans Schultes . And so, even though we have
this beautiful picture of the plant, no one
could actually identify what it was until
a much later period.
Hernandez talks about several different types
of agave.
The way it’s talked about on the Codex it’s
filled with the [inaudible] and that is the
root of the whole series of different kinds
of plants.
Several of which are talked about on the Mapa
Quetzalecatzin.
On the Codex there are a number of other different
kinds of place names.
Here we have the Nahua word for Valley of
the Lizards and beautiful leaf pictured with
a lizard on it.
And so there’s a lot of place names like
this.
Here we have Hummingbird Hill.
You can see the hummer here and the Nahua
word for hummingbird above it.
Some of the place name are a little bit more
interesting or a little bit stranger.
We have the Pueblo Tetelln which is “among
the mounds” and you can see very faded here
– here is the actual Nahua word.
You can see these mounds.
And I’m not sure if these slayed prisoners
have something to do with the mounds or something
to do with the river.
So it’s an extremely interesting place name
that we find on the Codex.
One of the most prominent features in the
map is Atoyac River.
And this is the river that runs the length
of the Codex.
And we know it’s the Atoyac River because
in fact, we are told that again, on the Codex.
And there’s a few things that are not indigenous
on the Mapa itself.
There’s a couple of churches on the which
just – on the map.
And, those two churches -- there’s one on
the very top, if you’re looking at a full
figure, and there’s one at the bottom.
They are actually in fact named with their
Nahua names and we can identify what these
two churches are.
This is the second one, there’s just a very
light bit of text right here which you can’t
read, but under imaging we were about to actually
read what this text is.
And so, we can actually construct where it
is, in fact, that this map is actually showing.
And although we can’t trace what are the
Hill of Red Agave or what the Lizard Valley
is we can see, in fact, that this is the location
if the northernmost church, which still survives,
which is the Church of Todos Santos in Ecatepec,
and then we have the Church of Santa Cruz.
And these two churches still exist and this
is -- the actual Mapa is oriented toward the
northeast so the top is, in fact – or the
northwest, the top is towards the, this top
is actually should be oriented towards the
northwest.
And really, the area that we’re talking
about now, most of the Codex, most of the
genealogical parts that we see talk about
these particular rulers not as rulers but
really as keepers.
And talking about them as people who keep
the land or who rent out the land.
And so, we’re really seeing a group of people
who are renting out, or sdfa obviously, pieces
of the territory from the northernmost part
here, north of Mexico City, to a little bit
south of Puebla.
And I’m not really sure what the attachments
to each of the -- either of the particular
places is, we see a lot of imagery on the
Codex of the wind god.
There’s a small lake on the Codex put onto
the left hand side which says it’s the source
of the winds.
The Atoyac River, by the way, flows right
through the valley here, so the Codex, or
the Mapa, is actually showing the river and
this particular piece of land.
So it’s a fairly interesting mapa from the
point that we can actually figure out where
the territory is quite easily because of those
two (post)colonial Spanish churches that exist
on the map itself.
Now, maps like this are interesting primary
source documents, not only for what they show
us about the Nahua culture, but also for what
they say about how the maps are in fact constructed.
And what we found on our particular codex
here is that the pigment’s that are used,
at least the red and the blue, the blue is
Maya blue, which is indigo mixed with a particular
kind of clay, and the red is Cochineal, which
is the extract of a scale insect that lives
on a particular kind of cactus locally.
So some of that information is quite interesting
in relating it to the actual practice of making
these kinds of manuscripts.
This manuscript has the interesting problem,
or the interesting [inaudible] is actually
on European paper, so multiple pieces of European
paper kind of glued together as opposed to
the traditional amatwa paper that we would
see in some of the other codexes at the Library.
Those Oztoipac Lands Map, which will be the
subject of the next webinar, and the Huexotzinco
Codex are bsoth on indigenous paper as opposed
to this particular codex that we’re dealing
with here.
Now, some things that we can hope for in the
future on research on this codex, it has been
in private hands for more than a hundred years
and has not been that accessible to scholars
around the world.
The Library Of Congress obtained the final
[inaudible] of the Codex which was completed
in late last year, in late November, early
December.
And the Library has in fact scanned the Codex
immediately.
The Librarian of Congress, Carla Hayden, actually
participated in the scanning of the manuscript
and we put it up online immediately.
So all of the high-resolution digital images
of the Codex are out there for anyone to look
at or study and we’re hoping that people
will grab onto that and we will be able to
get a lot more information on the history
of the Codex and the genealogy of the family
and really what the Codex was made for.
One of the opening questions in the history
of this particular manuscript is “for what
purpose was it actually made?”
And we’re looking forward to all of you
out there who are interested and all of the
scholars of Nahua who might listen in to
With that, I’ll just say that there’s
a couple of new webinars coming.
For these webinars, you can see the date in
front of you.
One is on April 11th, one on May 9th and I
can open it up for questions and we can have
a discussion.
Thanks so much John that was wonderful and
fascinating.
If there’s any questions that you have in
the chat, we have some questions about the
size, should I put the dimensions there.
And as to the ethnobotanical work, the link
is there.
But if there are any others, by all means, please add them
in the chat
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress. Visit us at loc.gov